This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
Within the little droplets of water we study
each week on Journey to the Microcosmos,
we have seen all the chaotic aspects of life that
we experience on a macro scale unfold between
the tiniest of organisms.
And through them, we’ve learned plenty of
lessons as stories of resilience and adaptation
unfold before us, like little microscopic
Aesop’s fables.
But Aesop probably would not have come up
with one of our favorite morals of the microcosmos:
never let anyone convince you that butts,
immortality, or sex
are easy to define or describe.
Now if we were to write a fable to get this moral
across, it would have to star the freshwater
cnidarian called the hydra, one of our favorite
stars of the microcosmos.
Because in the hydra, the question of butts
connects to the ambiguities of immortality,
which in turn relates to the befuddling matter
of sexual reproduction.
And in some species, it builds to a fantastic
reality where sex spells the beginning of the end.
But that’s jumping ahead.
Let’s start with what's usually the end
of the tale:
the butt, which in the hydra also double as
the mouth.
And for hydras, defining the mouth and the
butt is a bit of a complicated affair because much
of the time, there is no opening at all.
The area where the mouth belongs is a continuous
sheet of cells that ruptures open and expands
when the time comes to eat or to poop.
Imagining for a moment our own bodies
working this way is, horrifying.
There’s the fact that food would enter and
exit our bodies from the same location, and
then the wound inflicted from within to make
that possible.
But for hydras, this is casual, a part of
their daily habit of recycling cells and making
new ones that makes their bodies capable of
handling all sorts of things.
Their ability to do this is rooted in populations
of stem cells that are able to endlessly divide
to make different types of cells that can
patch the hydra right up.
Theoretically, a hydra could replace all of
the cells along its surface within a week.
Now there’s a number of philosophical
questions you could ask about this.
Is the hydra like the hypothetical ship whose
every part has been replaced by a new piece?
And if so, is a hydra with new cells still
even the same hydra?
It seems like we would have to say yes, especially
because it maintains the same sequence of DNA
—that molecular source of identity that
so often seems to define us.
But then what to make of a hydra that reproduces
asexually, budding off new little clones of
itself that swim away carrying that same DNA?
Are those clones part of the same original
hydra, or are they their own entities?
We could argue those questions all day, and
perhaps some of you will.
But we’re asking them not to get to an obvious
answer, but to instead have a little fun with
the fact that our definitions inevitably fall
short of what nature actually reveals.
As far as murkiness in nature goes, hydra
butts might be a little unusual.
But they are practically straightforward
compared to the question of immortality.
We’ve actually done an episode about immortality
before, and in it we said the following:
These stem cells may make the hydra biologically
immortal.
Because its cells are always being replaced,
the hydra is able to avoid the accumulation
of damage that other multicellular organisms
experience.
The hydra doesn’t age.
And so until another force or predator intervenes,
it doesn’t die.
Well, we sure did say something that sounded
uncomplicated there.
But, it turns out, we were a little bit wrong.
Not entirely wrong, just not entirely right
either.
And this is where the complicated question
of sex comes in.
This is Hydra viridissima, a species found
throughout the world and that’s notable
for the green color it gets thanks to the
Chlorella algae living symbiotically within it.
And, along this hydra’s body,
you can see tiny round structures with
something wiggling inside.
Those wiggling bits are immature sperm cells,
waiting to burst from the organ that encases them.
Eventually the sperm are released by the hydra
into the water in search of eggs to be fertilized.
Most of the year, none of that is happening.
The Hydra viridissima will reproduce asexually,
budding off its little clones.
But when the weather gets warmer, the population
shifts.
Individuals develop gonads that mark it as
male, female, or hermpaphroditic.
And for the female hydras, asexual reproduction
is put on pause.
Now that all sounds very simple and
like it follows a clear cycle.
But it’s also very specific to this species.
If you ever want to feel your brain turn completely to
mush, read a few scientific papers about hydra sex.
It’s not that hydra sex itself is particularly
complicated in its mechanics.
It’s just that it is very difficult to say
any kind of generality about the strategy
and effect of sexual reproduction in hydras
across species.
Some species spend most of their life reproducing
asexually.
Some alternate between asexual and sexual
reproduction.
Some rely on populations of hermaphroditic
individuals, others have a mix, and still
others have individuals that change their sex.
And that’s just a few of the details.
Hydra viridissima, for example, are called
“warm crisis” hydras because they tend
to shift towards sexual reproduction when
the waters get warmer.
In general, a shift from asexual to sexual
reproduction marks an attempt to survive through
variation, creating eggs or offspring that
might be able to weather the challenges of
an environment that a population of clones
might not.
And so, for the hydra viridissima, as waters
get warmer, the possibility of drought or
shifts in their food might signal the need
to become sexual reproducers.
But for other species of hydra, it’s not warmth
that triggers the switch.
It’s cold, the oncoming winter that makes
their environment harder and informs their
decision to change to sexual reproduction.
The species Hydra oligactis, for example,
has become a useful model for researchers
to study because all the hydras need to be
convinced to reproduce sexually is a little
chill in the water.
And yet, hydras are nothing if not wildly
inconsistent with one another, which means
there is another species, Hydra vulgaris,
that can begin reproducing sexually within
a few days of its birth with little care for
temperature of the water at all.
However, the most meaningful inconsistency
of all ties into one of the long-standing
debates about hydras:
are they immortal?
So what does immortality have to do with sex?
Well, for some hydras, nothing.
But for others, it’s everything, including
the end.
As we said before, hydras can of course die.
There are predators and forces of nature they
cannot escape.
But aging, well, that seems like something
they’ve never had to deal with before because
of that pool of constantly renewing stem cells
within them.
And for some of the species we’ve talked
about today, like Hydra viridissima and Hydra
vulgaris, those pools of cells just keep on
churning, keeping the animals ageless.
But for Hydra oligactus, our cold-weather
reproducer, a switch to sexual reproduction
puts a halt to all of that.
When the temperature drops and the hydra begins
to produce its sperm or eggs, the rest of
the animal begins to decline as well.
The cells within it begin to descend into
disarray, and over the time the hydra will
start to eat less and less.
In the lab, they will usually die within months.
But why?
There are a myriad of pathways within the
animal that seem to describe Hydra oligactis’
sudden but slow shift from an immortal to
aging animal.
And yet these changes in gene expression and
behavior don’t fully explain why this species
is so affected by the switch to sexual reproduction
while others—
like hydra viridissima—
are able to switch to and from different methods
of reproduction without any aging at all.
Buried in that mystery are the answers to
so many of our questions about how aging affects
our own bodies.
And perhaps some day we will find those answers,
nestled in between contradictions created by our own
attempts to define the world, to understand
it as best as we can with the tools we have
available to us, imperfect as they might be.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and beautiful
online platform from which to create their website.
Whether you're just starting out or you're
looking to grow your existing business, Squarespace
has everything you need to succeed.
So, let’s say you’re looking to create
a stunning online store for your fashion brand.
With Squarespace, you can create a beautiful
and professional-looking website that showcases
your unique style and brand.
And with the help of their third-party extensions,
you can easily manage inventory, streamline
bookkeeping, and ship products across the
world.
And if you're interested in blogging about
your fashion brand, Squarespace makes it easy
to create a blog that seamlessly integrates
with your online store.
You can share your latest collections, style
tips, and behind-the-scenes glimpses into
your creative process with your readers.
With Squarespace, you can also interact with
your customers and build a community of fashion
enthusiasts through threaded comments and
replies.
Sign up for a free trial at Squarespace.com to
start  building your online fashion boutique today.
And when you're ready to launch,
visit squarespace.com/microcosmos
to save 10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it possible for
us to continue exploring the truly bizarre
nature of the world that we get to live in.
It's a wonderful world, and the more we look,
the more bizarre we find it to be.
So thank you to them for helping us do this
work.
If you would like to become a patron on Patreon,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.